at this point in the evening the
projected winner of the Iowa caucuses um
has just started giving his victory
speech uh we will keep an eye on that
there is a reason that we and other news
organizations have generally stopped
giving an unfiltered live platform to
remarks by former president trump it is
not out of spite it is not a decision
that we relish Trump declaring Victory
with a historically strong showing in
the Iowa caucuses a relatively subdued
speech as these things go so far
although here he is right now under
under my voice you hear him repeating
his anti-immigrant
rhetoric trying to silence the GOP front
runner after he won the first major test
of the 2024 election okay you can't make
this up this is from the pro-democracy
crowd so my question tonight is what
happens in the general election are we
only going to hear from Biden when they
roll him out joining me now Victor Davis
hon and Hoover institution senior fellow
Victor I was in that room when Trump was
speaking last night and if they bothered
to listen to him he was actually saying
I want to work with Democrats to save
the cities I'll work with anybody to
save the C these are great cities and
they don't want to hear that because
what does that do
Victor well you know I think they think
that the more they have the bias Co
coverage and the more they spread
falsities about Trump they're like
straws on the proverbial Trump camel
back they can finally just overwhelm him
but in fact as we've seen the last year
or two the opposite is true the more
they lie and they do not apologize and
they do not correct the record and the
more they're found out the less
credibility they have and the more
popularity Donald Trump had in the
primaries and I think that's going to
extend to the general election because
they can't stop they have a trump fix
they're like an addict and they know
it's not helping them but they can't
stop it because they're addicted to it
and so they're going to continue what
you saw last night all through the next
year and I think what little credibility
they have left will be shot and it's
going to help Donald Trump you know I
think we forget that without these media
people the whole January 6 armed
Insurrection are the most of the lies
about the origins of covid and social
distancing and masking or the
circumstances of George Floyd's death
and the rioting that happened not to
mention disinformation on the laptop or
Russian collusion all of that wouldn't
have had any residents they fabricated
constructed exaggerated all of that and
yet it didn't destroy Donald Trump he's
got the most amazing political comeback
in American political history and I
think
that's the news media's
bias yeah but I again they keep backing
up and running faster into a brick wall
they kind of tiptoed toward the wall and
they bumped their head and they backed
up they went a little fast a little now
now they're running at full speed and at
some point they're going to knock
themselves out Victor and it it just I I
I mean I don't know who they think is
voting I mean these are real Americans
who are really supporting Trump so I
guess it just confirms what everyone
thinks that these people literally hate
despise the caucus vot voters goers in
Iowa they despise them because they're
racist they're too white they're this or
that they hate
them well they do we've known that for a
long time I mean look at the vocabulary
they've used clingers from Obama and
then CH Chumps and drags from Biden
deplorables irredeemables and lately
people like Chris Matthews have been
warning us about the dangerous rural
people so they've always despised them
but you know now they have a new
narrative that Trump is a dictator he's
going to have Revenge retribution that
shows the that they're really scared
that nobody's listening to their lives
anymore and they're afraid that it's had
the it's counterproductive and now they
all they can say is Trump might get
elected and he might do this and this he
might do what we would do if we were in
his position and had suffered from us so
it's it's a projection it it it reflects
weakness not strength I think they've
had I don't think they have much
credibility and they're losing the
independent they're losing uh minority
voters because of the lying and the
falsity all right Victor we appreciate
it thank you so much hey Sean hanity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else